I had to get out I had to do this thing
that people in New York do which is go
upstate you know I had to like like went
up to like a cabin in Woodstock it was
it was did you really yeah yeah for like
a night by myself just so do you get the
lights on all night
um oh my why because you're scared yeah
because somebody was gonna come in and
kill me obviously I was in the woods
what else is there to do but come in and
kill me yeah I'd be you know I'd be
thinking about cocaine bear I think oh
yeah I haven't seen it is it good I
loved it yeah I can't stop talking about
that [__] movement I loved it wow
something about it Elizabeth Banks
directed and produced or just produced
Elizabeth I think she directed it very
cool she's great
wait gut click Elizabeth Banks director
hell yeah and I think she's awesome yeah
she's [__] awesome yeah yeah and
she's so funny and 30 I always remember
how funny she was in 30 Rock too she's
so talented I mean yeah cocaine barrels
is so
so dumb but like yeah in just the
funnest way yeah yeah I gotta go watch
it and I'm pretty sure this is like Ray
Liotta's last role uh did you see him in
um
did you guys see him in marriage story
it was so good it's just like cocaine
bear it's sort of this
same kind of movie action animal
no but Ray Liotta sometimes I I was
because rayleon is in marriage story and
his acting is is so good that I feel
like I'm it's like a drug it's like he's
so
real you know what does he do in cocaine
bear Ray Liotta yeah yeah he's like the
the bear he's the bear he plays the yeah
he wore one of those like motion
tracking suits and just acted like a
bear and then they CGI the bear on top
of him right right and then he's also in
the movie as a human oh it's crazy yeah
oh and then there's this guy from those
Ikea Tick Tock wait what you know this
yeah yeah yeah I wonder if we can play
so there's so this guy he he got you
know it's very cool he like sort of came
from the internet like many of us and um
and he's in he's in cocaine but this guy
Scott is he Swedish how do you say his
last name seis uh no he's I uh he's
either American or Canadian I don't know
I feel like I almost heard a Canadian
accent but he um he okay so he used to
do these tick tocks I feel like you've
seen them because they they they're
around where he's like he's got a fake
Ikea background yeah there it is are we
do we play it or no I could just if
there's music then no but if there's not
I think they're I think there's that
Tick Tock music you know basically he's
hit the [__] let's just see it first
yeah yeah
yourself a customer you think I own this
business
you think I own IKEA I'm a part-time
employee halfway through a two-week
notice [__] I go to the sale ended last
week but can I still get a discount do
you hear yourself
we can't go backwards this is not the
same guy is it that's it from 15 years
ago too when's it end Diane yeah yeah
yeah
so this isn't like specifically you can
pause it this isn't specifically about
Ikea this is just like he just picked a
store and this is about being I think he
maybe worked at Ikea I think part of the
stories he worked at Ikea and I think I
don't want to say things that aren't
true but I think he got fired from Ikea
because of these so these are these are
very real yeah yeah visceral Revenge
what what is the I love that Ikea what
is that comment uh
um
I love that Ikea had to come out and say
he does not speak for our employees
meanwhile their employees are like yes
he does yes he does
oh so these like blew up then these were
huge yeah and he I think you know sort
of got cocaine bear off of his his
online presence which is cool really but
I gotta watch cocaine bear so I see what
he's what he's up to in it he's good
he's definitely good in it I mean yeah
it's
what else happens the berries cocaine
and then it kills people it's just like
yeah he's a song on a crazy cocaine
binge he just like wants more of it so
and they're trying to get it back
because they're like dealers
they lost the drugs in the forest
they're trying to get it back so they
can sell it do they know they owe
someone else money his belly are they
trying to get it out of his belly
there's a bunch of Coke
and he then the bear wants more of it
um okay so they're not trying to get out
of the bear because there's more lying
around okay okay yeah he's uh do you see
that that like tweet down went viral I
think yesterday did before it's like
people people say that bears are scary
then explain this and it's just like
pictures of their ears
the cute little I know bears are so cute
they really are I used to think bears
were dogs
in the same way that you know how lions
and tigers are cats it's not just that
they're related cats like those are cat
videos cats and China animals too and
China animals are related to China
um I I thought bears in the same way
were big dogs but they're not they're
their own they're their own category
what and I think why did you think that
to what age like two years ago yeah this
is recently debunked in my 30s
look at their little ears and seals too
it's like dogs yeah like Sea Dogs yeah
seal uh walrus aren't those all kind of
dogs I thought they were just like a
differently evolved dog it's a sick name
for a band Sea Dogs well Sea Dogs is a
real term I think I think it's right if
you start to see dogs seals they're dogs
of the sea yeah can we find out if this
is because they do kind of bark yeah
an old experienced sailor
a mythical Beast like a dog with fins so
I went ahead and got this wrong yeah
this is not a Sea Dog wait no but look
they are okay oh that's what you thought
on all the way on the right
yeah exactly they've got to see pugs
NFC from Logan Paul's Zoo thing
my new Sea Dog nft
yeah yeah but I thought that yeah I
thought bears were dogs
what else oh did you guys know that um
things so in evolution right most things
that kind of look alike are connected
but there's this other thing where
I think it's called carsonification or
something things keep evolving
independently into crabs so there's lots
of things that are crabs or sort of look
like crabs that aren't connected like
they're they're not related to each
other they involved independently
because being a crab is such an
evolutionarily advantageous position
it's like why a lot of things would lead
you to want to ultimately be a crap
what's so good about being a crowd
you're protected you have a legs I think
those are the main ones you have awesome
awesome claws yeah look uh
carsonization is an example of
convergent evolution in which you gotta
read this one in an accident yeah an
example of conversion evolution in which
a crustacean evolves into a crab-like
form from a non-crab like form right
right the term is introduced into
evolutionary biology by La Bora borado
who described it as one of the many
attempts of nature to evolve a crab
basically you have to watch out that you
don't involve into it yeah but I do
sometimes feel
yeah yeah like the urge to like weird
sort of crustacean urges exactly you can
feel the clamping yeah exactly yeah yeah
I mean I a crab that wouldn't strike me
as the most evolutionary advantageous I
know exactly like they're so [__]
easy to rip apart you know
they do run really fast though if you
try to catch one in the wild he's like
that's true actually yeah yeah and they
are kind of like they have that sort of
uh
like getting a lot of like Predators
like right like ew like stay away stay
away from that thing it's Got Claws like
it's gonna pinch me I know it's so like
scuttily and weird yeah do you ever have
a little hermit crab as a kid no do you
ever like cats
did you ever catch little animals and
keep them just a Kill
crabs I feel like yeah where I'm from
yeah caterpillar
butterfly yeah
full like I never had like no I never I
never had like an ant
yeah yeah yeah
I would catch caterpillars and I would
sort of think they were my friends and
then they would kind of just die
eventually you know a little box and
that's how you learned about death
exactly so and about mortality yeah
laughs
um
yeah oh my God how do you get it to stop